this is from fox news it says a
ten-year-old boy a florida boy slammed
his local school board during a public
meeting last week calling the district's
mask mandate unfair to kids during an
emergency session on reopening
guidelines
the boy later identified as john begins
by describing himself as a student at
felix a williams elementary school in
martin county
um and we'll play the some of his
remarks in just a second but
not to get not the spoiler alert here
not to spoil the ending but following
his remarks the board voted 4-1
to keep masks mandatory for the
remaining days of the current school
year
in spite of what he had to say the kids
pleading with them can we take the masks
off
there's no reason for us to have the
masks on to begin with uh they they
elected to keep the masks on anyway but
i thought uh this kid i mean he's 10
years old
and this is pretty eloquent
for anyone of any age let alone a 10
year old let's uh let's listen
i expected school to be a little bit
different
in the beginning but i didn't think it
would stay
this way all year long and i was
surprised by the rules
a lot of them didn't make any sense to
me like the fact that we were not
allowed to play on the playground or
have student council
or turn to face each other at lunch and
we also have to wear masks outside at pe
and
on track i love my school now but my
teachers seem really stressed
and that makes me feel bad one teacher
walks around with a clipboard full of
referrals for any student whose mask
isn't on properly
it makes me feel scared that same
teacher yells at us having our mask down
to drink water while we are outside in
car line
she told us we had to wait until we were
in our parents car to have a drink of
water
she had her mask down the entire time
while she was yelling at
us which makes me and all my friends
very mad
my mask also sticks to my face when it's
really hot and it makes it hard to
breathe
i feel like i can't catch my breath and
that makes me feel claustrophobic and
anxious
it's really stressful i finished
taking all of my fsas and i had a hard
time focusing with a mask on
a few weeks ago i ran into my teacher
outside of school she didn't even
recognize
me because she's never seen my face
before
that that is that last part there is
just sad it's also sad that this is a 10
year old boy
making a far more compelling argument
against wearing masks
than any adult on the other side of the
issue has made in favor of
of children wearing the masks because
they've never made any argument at all
really
it's it's it's their own fear and uh
and in disregard for the kids that's all
it is
there's never really any argument
presented and he
that was longer than that he went on for
two and a half three minutes um
again ten-year-old boy laying out the
case this is why we don't we should be
wearing the masks
trying to explain it to adults four or
five times his age
makes no difference they keep the masks
in place anyway
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated